[MUSIC PLAYING]
MIKE ABRAMS: Please
welcome to the stage
the stars of the show, Nick
Frost, Lena Headey, Florence
Pugh, Jack Lowden, and
WWE Superstar Paige.
[APPLAUSE]
FLORENCE PUGH: We came
in out of order, sorry.
MIKE ABRAMS: That's fine.
That's fine.
Come on down.
NICK FROST: Hello.
Hello, everyone.
JACK LOWDEN: Hello.
MIKE ABRAMS: Well, thank
you all for being here.
Let's start with, can you mind
doing a brief introduction,
who you are, who you play, where
everyone recognizes you from?
NICK FROST: Hello, my
name is Nick Frost,
and I play Ricky Knight.
LENA HEADEY: Are you done?
NICK FROST: Yeah.
If you don't know where
I'm from, Google me.
[LAUGHTER]
Because, yeah.
PAIGE: My name is Paige, and
this movie is about my life,
and don't Google me.
It's so funny.
Your turn.
FLORENCE PUGH: I'm Florence
Pugh, and I play her in life
all the time.
LENA HEADEY: Lena Headey.
I play Paige's mom.
JACK LOWDEN: And I'm Jack, and
I play Zak, the brother who's
also over there ominously lit.
LENA HEADEY: Oh,
that's terrifying.
JACK LOWDEN: Genuinely is.
MIKE ABRAMS: So Paige, let's
kick this off with you.
For many of you that--
PAIGE: Come on, granddad.
Your turn.
MIKE ABRAMS: For many
of you that don't know,
there was actually
a TV documentary
that was made about your
family that, kind of, started
a little bit of this picture.
What's it like at this
stage in your career,
very early on, young, to have
a TV documentary and a biopic
about with The Rock?
PAIGE: Well, when it
comes to the documentary,
I was very used to being
in front of the camera,
because, you know,
my mom and dad
loved to do a documentary
or two growing up.
So me and Zak were kind of
used to that kind of stuff.
We didn't realize
that the documentary
was going to be so successful.
So it won awards, and we
were really happy about it.
But again, you don't
think anything of it
after that until Dwayne
approached me one day
and said, hey, we're going
to make a movie on you.
And that's, like,
so bizarre to me.
It's very surreal.
So, yeah, and it's very strange
to see a girl playing you too.
And she just did
such a fantastic job.
She made me look so much
better than I actually am.
And I'm just really
thankful for the cast too.
They're absolutely
incredible, apart from Nick.
NICK FROST: She's kidding.
She's kidding.
MIKE ABRAMS: You didn't
get to meet Paige
until after the shooting.
So what was it like being
able to pick someone who's
real, who's alive, who's
still very much in, kind
of, the early stage
of the career,
to build your own
character that was you
and not necessarily just
an impersonation of Paige?
FLORENCE PUGH: So many
questions in that.
Yeah, I didn't meet her.
Sorry, I have a slight cough.
I didn't meet her until about
three weeks ago, which I think,
now looking back
on it, I'm quite
glad I didn't, because I think
I would have been studying you
probably a bit creepily.
But at the time,
Paige was injured,
and she had her neck injury
and couldn't fly over,
and we started filming.
So we were just in
contact all the time.
Very odd playing
someone that's not
only alive but only a couple
of years older than you.
And this only happened
a couple of years ago.
So she doesn't need
her memory refreshing.
She knows about it all.
So I suppose you just have
to take the opportunity
and hope that you're not going
to offend or, most of the time,
you hope that you're going
to do the story justice.
And also, I suppose,
make sure that I
find some peace
in that storyline
that I need to tell as well.
So you have to make some
sort of amalgamation and then
just fingers crossed,
because she can wrestle,
so you hope she doesn't
find it offensive.
PAIGE: That's a true story.
FLORENCE PUGH: Yeah.
MIKE ABRAMS: And along
those same lines,
you were able to
watch a lot of YouTube
and film because of so much of
her being on stage and on TV.
How much did you prep
and watch for that?
FLORENCE PUGH: I mean, that's
the best thing about playing
a famous wrestler is that every
single fight she's ever done
is on there.
And even the documentary
was just so helpful to use,
because you can see what she
was like when she was younger
and around her family
and how they spoke.
And actually, getting
the accent down,
that was really handy to
watch the documentary.
MIKE ABRAMS: Jack,
you play the brother.
Kind of a very, very
big part of this,
take a lot of the emotional
toll through this.
I'm curious about with you doing
a big core of the wrestling,
how much training went
into, how much of the stunts
did you do to prepare
for such a physical role?
JACK LOWDEN: Quite a lot.
I was-- Zak is a big lad,
as we call them back home.
He's a unit.
Like, he's-- there's
just a lot of Zak.
And I really wasn't.
I was sort of wafer thin,
and kind of pathetic looking,
and told that very quickly by
our director that I needed to,
sort of-- there was a lot of
work to do to kind of do him
justice.
And so then they also gave
me six weeks to do that.
And so I had to eat like
four or five meals a day.
I was given a trainer, CrossFit
training, which is mental,
and I did that twice a day.
So did Flow.
So I'd get--
I remember the first
day I did it, actually.
I mean, I barely did anything
in the grand scheme of things,
but went home, and I fell
asleep at 3:00 in the afternoon.
And I was only 26 at the time,
so that's quite embarrassing.
But I did.
I ended up putting on
two, roughly two stone.
So I went from 79
kg to about 90 kg.
But that still wasn't even
anywhere near the size
that Zak was.
He's just huge.
But and then we
were lucky enough
to go over to the NXT in Florida
for a week, a week and a half,
and do some training with
some guys that were like--
they were all like 60, 75
years old, and sort of all
walked around with their
hands behind their backs.
And it was all disapproving
looks, and sort
of very little information.
And it was wonderful though.
And it was just
hilarious that you
had all these professional
wrestlers going
through all their
moves so beautifully,
and then me and
Florence Pugh just,
sort of, huffing and puffing.
But in a good way, I think.
But it was very, very
difficult, but very enjoyable
to try and get near
the size of Zak.
And it does-- even just
athletically, obviously,
it helps.
But I loved the way it felt
to, sort of, carry yourself
being bigger than that.
I've always dreamed of being
anywhere near that size.
And it was, yeah,
my favorite thing,
one of my favorite
things about playing him.
But the emotional
storyline of it.
This is-- I'm realizing,
as I'm speaking this,
this is the first time
I've spoken about this
in front of the real Zak.
So it's a little bit weird.
But his story is
actually remarkable.
MIKE ABRAMS: Yeah.
Let's get into that.
I mean, that's a big
part of the movie
is the emotional storyline
of not being selected,
and then a new baby,
a lot going on there.
And you kind of carry the
emotional roller coaster
of the character
throughout the movie.
How did you, I guess,
prepare for that
and cover that while also
doing all the physicality
of the wrestling aspect?
JACK LOWDEN: I think
it's a really cool thing
that it's been explored.
And I think he's an
incredibly honest human being.
And I think everybody's
probably dealt with,
to some extent in their
life, a dream that they had
and it maybe not coming true.
And I think in
the script, I hope
it's sort of true enough
to what actually happened.
But you know, it hits that
quite hard in the film.
And as an actor, you
know, I've obviously--
all of us have
experienced that, where
there's a brilliant scene
in it where he brings up
the guy who auditioned
him for the WWE,
basically to say
give us another go.
And I mean, I've
definitely thought
of doing that after auditions
that have gone horrendously.
And so it was quite cool to do.
It really was.
It made it really interesting.
PAIGE: I love that scene.
LENA HEADEY: Me too.
JACK LOWDEN: It's--
MIKE ABRAMS: A powerful scene.
JACK LOWDEN: Well, I'm
glad it was, because--
I did it with a
guy who was lying
in the footwell of the car.
He's-- in that scene, there's
this little Canadian bloke
lying there, like, squeezed
up like that with sides,
with giving me utterly nothing.
So I had to stick my finger
in my eye and do all the fake
crying I could.
MIKE ABRAMS: And Zak was
on set with you a lot.
So you got to kind
of work with him
and meet him throughout the--
JACK LOWDEN: Zak's in the film.
MIKE ABRAMS: Mm hmm.
JACK LOWDEN: So there is an even
weirder moment where Zak plays
the drug dealer in the film.
And I pull up in a
van and look at him,
and he says something to me.
So that was utterly bizarre.
Really, really weird.
But he's a remarkable
human being.
And I went up to Norwich.
I was given a chance to
go up there and watch
him run the WEW, which
is their company.
And for me, it's
better than the WWE.
I'm a massive fan of
amateur and semi pro sport.
I'm a big semi pro
football fan back--
soccer ball back in the UK.
And people who have that
much passion and who do it
for a tenth of the money,
even no money, I think
is, in my opinion,
way more impressive.
And I think what
he's done, and he's
such an enormous part
of his community,
I really take my hat off to him.
He's amazing.
MIKE ABRAMS: Yeah, and teaching
a blind wrestler is a big part
of that too in the movie.
JACK LOWDEN: Yeah, and
that's a verbatim true story.
He taught a blind
kid how to wrestle.
You think you've done
something well in life,
and then someone tells
you that a human being
taught a blind kid to wrestle.
Like, you're really
not trying that hard.
MIKE ABRAMS: Yeah.
Nick, I want to touch on
the father figure, Ricky,
who talks multiple times about
being a violent crime offender,
of going to prison
for violent crimes.
You've done a lot of comedy.
How did you take
that character that
has kind of a rough
around the edges,
but also is the
cornerstone of family,
and really doing what's best for
them, and bring your version?
NICK FROST: I don't know.
I mean, I think I'm
always keen to point out
that comedy and drama are
not mutually exclusive.
Do you know what I mean?
There's comedy in
everything, even funerals.
You know?
That's-- I don't think you
can just be funny and not feel
the other emotions
that a human may feel.
I think Ricky was a dream for me
to play, really, because it's--
as an actor, it's everything
you really want to be.
You want someone who's a
bit funny and is emotional
and is a lunatic.
He was a treat.
And I kind of--
I mean, me and Zak
and stuff today,
and getting to know
Paige a little bit,
and seeing the
documentary, I mean,
they're a lot like
my own family.
You know, my own brother
was a lot like Zak.
He was a bit of a loony, but
with a good heart, good egg.
And I think with
Ricky, I like the fact
that so often you see
a character who is bad
or who has made a mistake, and
there's not much redemption,
and I like the fact
that, yes, he did that,
and he was those
things, but he's also
a passionate father
and husband, and I
guess dynamite in the sack.
LENA HEADEY: Your mom's nodding.
PAIGE: Mom, stop nodding.
FLORENCE PUGH: Mom's nodding.
JACK LOWDEN: Who is that?
You're nodding as well.
Why are you nodding?
NICK FROST: But he's a dream
to play for me personally,
because especially with
Stephen, the director, you know,
he was he was keen.
I added a little something
in, and I didn't want
to do an impression of Ricky.
I wanted to do a kind
of an impression of who
he was as a man.
You know?
MIKE ABRAMS: Yeah.
And so you bring up Stephen,
and a of the dialogue, I mean,
it's very quick, very witty.
How did you kind of embrace that
and bring that into the piece?
There was so much
back and forth.
We saw a couple of the
jokes, the Vin Diesel
joke, and all these other pieces
in there that you throw in.
NICK FROST: Yeah, I mean,
it's quite limp on the page,
and the actors really
bring it to life, I think.
I don't know.
You know, Stephen wrote a
great script, and we had fun,
and we had the
time to muck about.
And once you've honored
what has been written,
there was always time
for something looser
or an improvisation, or if
one of us had a better idea,
we were allowed a voice.
And that's always-- plus, I
think we all like each other,
and the crew was great.
LENA HEADEY: Sort of.
Yeah.
NICK FROST: And I think it--
some of us like each other,
and the crew was great.
And I think that, for
me personally, that
gives you an ease, and
the fact you trust people
enough to put a bit of yourself,
leave a bit of yourself
out there.
You know?
I mean what bit is?
MIKE ABRAMS: Yeah.
NICK FROST: Sometimes
it was just liquid.
But other times
spirit and heart, you
know, but a lot of liquid.
PAIGE: Yeah, just to say that
Stephen really transport--
he took away from
the documentary
and put it onto
page really well.
I think that was
something that stood out
to me was watching
the documentary
and falling in love with
that family was exactly
the same as the way that
Stephen had put it down.
And I think that's a
testament to say how good he
did with the script.
MIKE ABRAMS: So Lena,
I wanted to ask you.
You know, you talked
about bad characters.
You're pretty famous for
playing a bad character on TV.
What was it like, kind
of, taking the TV big hit
and playing into a
movie, and a mom,
and someone who's here and as a
character and kind of embracing
her role?
LENA HEADEY: I, well, I'm
such a big fan of Julia.
I think she's an
incredible woman.
And I watched a lot.
I watched the documentary,
and I watched interviews
that she did.
And she's had a really
interesting, sometimes tricky
history.
And so she's such a sort of
powerful, resilient person.
And like Nick said,
it's like, you don't
want to do an impersonation.
You want to do--
you want to portray
someone with respect
and bring in who
they are at the core.
And all these characters are
such big, joyous honest people
that fuck up, and do really
well, and nothing's hidden.
Like, everything's
just out on the table,
which is why you can't not
fall in love with them.
And I didn't want
Julia to beat me up.
So that's a problem, right?
MIKE ABRAMS: And
how much training
did you two go through?
I mean, you definitely have
scenes in the movie where
you're in the ring, and did
you do a lot of training
for the wrestling part?
NICK FROST: We wrestled,
yeah, didn't we.
LENA HEADEY: We wrestled.
NICK FROST: [INAUDIBLE]
together, and--
LENA HEADEY: We tongue wrestled.
NICK FROST: It was good.
I was always--
I like wrestling.
I was a keen wrestler,
a keen amateur wrestler.
I've wrestled men in pubs
and privately in my own home.
And I'd always loved
wrestlers boots.
I was always fascinated,
always was like, oh,
my god, their boots are amazing.
And then when we
started to do the film,
they said, so we're going to
make you all handmade wrestling
boots.
I was like, oh, my god,
this is incredible.
But it's to kind of get
boots on and have a wrestle.
And the ring was very hard,
and noisy, and squeaky,
and it was great.
Right?
We had fun.
FLORENCE PUGH: It was a lot of.
NICK FROST: Anyone?
LENA HEADEY: Yeah.
No, I loved it.
I loved it.
I was saying earlier, I can
recognize everyone by smell.
Truth.
MIKE ABRAMS: So Paige,
when you saw the film,
you know, you have
this amazing cast,
how did you feel that
they depicted your family?
PAIGE: Oh, they killed it.
And I'm not just
saying that because I'm
sitting on stage with them,
or it's about my story,
but they really did kill
it, because 95% of the movie
was very true to story.
And they didn't get to
spend any time with us,
like, at all, apart from Jack
a little bit with Zaky boy
over there.
But I just thought it was--
I cried my eyes out.
Like, the first time I
watched it, like, I couldn't--
blobbering everywhere.
I couldn't get through
the whole movie,
because I was just crying,
because I was like--
these guys are just, like--
it's so perfectly done,
and Stephen did such a
good job on the script.
Enough where-- so I don't know
if you guys have seen it or not
yet or you're about
to see it, but they
say some pretty crude stuff.
Right?
Some crazy stuff that's
just [INAUDIBLE]..
But Stephen said,
like, all he had to do
is pretty much follow my
parents around with a notepad,
and the script pretty
much wrote itself.
And people always think
that it's not real,
but that's literally
who they are.
And these guys just
absolutely killed it.
And the thing that broke my
heart the most was seeing--
Jack did such a good
job playing my brother.
And the wonderful
part of Zak's story
is the fact that it
kind of shows you
that you don't have to be
successful in the way-- it
shouldn't be measured.
Sorry.
Your level of success shouldn't
be measured by how famous
you are, or how many people
you have on Instagram,
or how many cameras are
in front or your face,
or how many people you are
doing interviews in front of.
Success is reaching a goal
that you set for yourself.
For example, Zak
wanted a family,
and now he has two kids.
And Zak wanted to train disabled
children how to wrestle,
and now he has someone
with Down syndrome
who wants to learn
how to wrestle,
someone who is blind who
wants to learn how to wrestle.
You know?
And also, you want to be
part of my dad's company,
which you know, if
you guys want shares,
my dad said they were available.
NICK FROST: I've got
the paperwork in my bag.
PAIGE: I feel like
Jack just portrayed
that in such a wonderful
way, and it just
completely broke my heart,
especially that scene.
It was absolutely incredible.
I was like--
I wanted to call Jack
like, I'm so sorry dude.
But yeah, they just did
such an incredible job.
And I'm sorry the answer was
really long, but I loved it.
MIKE ABRAMS: Another
big theme of the movie
is, I think The
Rock says the line,
but don't try to be the
next me, be the first you.
How did you embrace that?
I mean, when you came on
stage, being from Norwich,
and with all the models,
and the different pieces
in the movie that you--
PAIGE: Yeah.
It was a little bit different.
Yeah.
Well, when I first
came over here,
I didn't know
anything about makeup.
I was wearing my
brothers hand-me-downs,
and I didn't have
to brush my hair.
Still don't.
And it was just--
it was very strange.
I was very insecure.
Like, I was confident
enough to know,
OK, I'm going to be
in the WWE, and I'm
going to fight until I make
it, but it's another story
once you come over here
to a different country.
It was a big culture shock,
and it was just so different,
because the women
were so beautiful.
The kind of ones that you see in
slow motion with smoke machines
and doves flying behind them.
And they're just like, ha,
and I'm just like damn.
And then there's me
and my frumpy jackets
and baggy clothes, and like,
smelled probably really bad.
You know, like, they're
just so beautiful.
And so I was real insecure.
But the one thing, even
though I was super lonely,
I didn't have any friends
when I first came over here.
Still don't.
But-- fuck.
But no, the one thing that
I did have was my family,
and they just made me feel
like I was very unique.
In that case, I was there.
And someone told me
before that being yourself
is your superpower.
So I kind of took
that and was, like,
I tried to be something
I wasn't, which
is when I lightened my hair,
and took my piercings out,
and got tan, which
is so strange for me.
But I kind of took that
after a couple of months
of being there and crying
my eyes out and embracing
it and being like, you know
what, fuck you, this is me.
That's just how it was.
And then I kind of ran with
that, and now we're here.
MIKE ABRAMS: So there's
a lot about perseverance,
wanting to quit.
I think that's very relevant
too for the acting world, where
it takes a lot to kind of
get to that level of success.
How did that
storyline kind of play
to you as actors in your career?
Open ended for any of you.
JACK LOWDEN: It obviously
plays a massive part.
You know, you're not
saving lives doing this.
You know, you have to enjoy it.
In my opinion, you're
obliged to enjoy it.
It's your responsibility
to enjoy it.
And it's remarkable how often--
I'm probably not speaking
for just me either.
So it's remarkable how often
it's not enjoyable when--
because it's so about
you, this profession.
It's so you.
It's not, like, what you do.
You can't do your work,
and then stand back
and people can
look at your work.
It's you.
And I totally took that for
granted before I got into this.
And sort of, it's gotten easier
and harder at the same time.
And so it's exactly
what these guys do.
You know, what they do is the
perfect combination of sport
and drama.
It really is.
It honestly is the
best night I've ever
had when I went up there.
It's tremendous.
And it's full blooded as well.
You know a lot of
people in our profession
get, like, a lot of credit for
being method, or going deep,
and all this, kind
of, stuff that they
like to say that makes them
sound a lot sexier than they
actually are.
But like, if you want
to see going deep,
go and watch the WEW.
Like, their commitment
in front of an audience
is extraordinary.
And also, to do what
they do, and not
in front of an audience
that's that much bigger
than the audience we have now.
Like, you know, the WWE,
with all due respect,
they're in front
of 20,000 people.
It's probably quite easy to
get jacked up and get into it.
But to do it in front of not
a great deal amount of people
is even more impressive.
And it's kind of like doing a
fringe show at the Edinburgh
Festival when you do
a play in like a cafe.
Like, it's a lot, lot harder.
So the respect level's
huge for what they do.
MIKE ABRAMS: Anybody else have
any thoughts on that topic?
No.
JACK LOWDEN: Yahoo.
MIKE ABRAMS: Yeah.
No.
LENA HEADEY: I think
Jack covered it.
MIKE ABRAMS: Jack covered it.
Perfect.
So what was it like
having "The Rock"
Dwayne Johnson's
involvement in this.
There's a lot of parallels to
his family and to your family.
How much of that, having him
being a producer on this,
played into a little bit more
of the overall wrestling family
piece of this picture?
PAIGE: Is that an open question.
MIKE ABRAMS:
Open-ended question.
PAIGE: Oh.
MIKE ABRAMS: Yeah.
NICK FROST: Me?
Oh, I never met "The
Rock" until last week,
so I was really nervous.
I'd never-- I was a big fan,
and I was a fan of "The Rock"
for years, and then I kept
talking to the producer,
kind of saying, hey is "The
Rock" ever going to come down,
or--
yeah, "The Rock"
didn't ask about--
he's not ever seen
"Hot Fuzz" has he?
You know, just keep
dropping hints and stuff,
and he never got in touch.
So then I saw him
last week at Sundance,
and I was fairly nervous.
And I practiced three or
four different versions
of how I would meet him.
And then in the end, when you're
faced with such a Colossus,
all that falls to the side, and
you're just left saying, hey.
And that was it.
That was kind of all I got out.
But I don't know.
I mean, he looks
good in the poster
that he wasn't there for.
LENA HEADEY: Did you send him
your "Jumanji" audition tape?
NICK FROST: No.
I keep mentioning
"Jumanji 2" a lot,
hoping there'll be some kind
of trickle-down casting.
But I haven't heard.
I haven't checked today, but I
haven't heard whether or not--
I mean, I think they're
starting to fill up
their roster of actors.
I know Danny Glover
recently got cast, but--
LENA HEADEY: I met him
at Sundance briefly,
and he didn't know who I
was when I was leaving the--
and we did it.
I went, hey, and he
went, hi, and I went--
that was my exchange.
FLORENCE PUGH: In all
seriousness though,
he did work.
I'm sorry, but I'm going to
give them some good things now.
JACK LOWDEN: Like he needs help.
FLORENCE PUGH: He
needs a bit of help.
Jack and I worked with him.
Obviously, on our
first day of shoot,
he did scene where he
shouted at us for 40 minutes.
LENA HEADEY: [INAUDIBLE].
FLORENCE PUGH: Yeah.
It was fun.
He's really big.
He eats a lot.
And I keep on saying that he
looks really smooth, because he
does look really smooth.
But no, we had a great time,
and we were both just so amazed
by how--
he basically went
away and wrote that,
and then we exchanged
lines to figure out
what we were going
to say, and then
he walked away and came
back 20 minutes later,
and he knew this
huge monologue promo,
and he just basically
barked at us.
It was amazing.
And then also,
towards the end, I
did at Paige's fight
in the Staples Center
after Monday Night Raw,
and he was very much
involved with the wrestling.
So that was really
lovely of him.
And yeah, those were the
times that we worked together.
MIKE ABRAMS: So I do want to
open up to audience questions.
So if people want to line up,
we have two mics on both sides.
While people are lining up, I
have a fun question for you,
and I'm--
if you were-- this
is more for the cast,
since Paige's has
already been picked.
If you were a WWE wrestler,
what would your stage name be,
and what would your
finishing move be?
FLORENCE PUGH: Lena
has a really good one.
It's called choo-choo.
LENA HEADEY: Yeah.
FLORENCE PUGH: She
comes on choo-chooing.
LENA HEADEY: It's
like a locomotive.
FLORENCE PUGH: As
she choo-choos.
LENA HEADEY: And
my fuel is farts.
And I just release
one long deadly one.
FLORENCE PUGH: Choo-choo.
LENA HEADEY: Choo-choo, and
just everyone [INAUDIBLE]..
I don't have to touch anyone.
FLORENCE PUGH: No,
she's going to eat--
NICK FROST: Has that ever
been done in the WWE?
LENA HEADEY: No.
PAIGE: Oh, actually
Natty, which is--
she's a Hart, one part
of The Hart Foundation.
She had to fart on screen a
lot and not notice the fact
that she was farting.
But Vince thought
it was hilarious,
so she had to do it for months.
So she's standing in
front of people just like,
[FARTING NOISE],, and that
was all she had to do.
FLORENCE PUGH: Wow.
PAIGE: For, like, months,
she got paid to fart.
NICK FROST: But did they
have a thing in her trousers
where smoke would come out?
Because that's how
choo-choo would end.
PAIGE: No, WWE's
not that dramatic.
LENA HEADEY: She's
got green gas.
Yeah.
FLORENCE PUGH: Imagine calling
your dad and being like,
dad, dad, I did it.
Yeah, I'm playing the farter.
PAIGE: Thank god they're
not making me queef.
I knew mom would like that one.
MIKE ABRAMS: Anybody else
have a wrestling name?
No?
JACK LOWDEN: I would
be called rump steak.
And he wouldn't be so
much of a wrestler.
I thought he would
just be around the ring
dressed in like dressing gown.
It comes from my prison name.
If I went to prison, I was told
that I would be kind of known
as, sort of, rump steak,
and sort of passed around
in a sort of chewy kind of way.
And I kind of think rump steak
could fill that kind of spot
in wrestling.
So he's not featured.
He's just always there at
every single wrestling match.
And he just walks about
in a dressing gown.
And it's just, sort of,
when he's given the signal,
he just comes on, and it's there
just to be used in any way.
FLORENCE PUGH: Does
he cook you steak?
JACK LOWDEN: No.
FLORENCE PUGH: Does he
have, like, a [INAUDIBLE]..
LENA HEADEY: Can I just say,
hearing that, never ever
do anything wrong.
JACK LOWDEN: What?
LENA HEADEY: Never do anything
that sends you to prison,
just having heard that.
JACK LOWDEN: Yeah.
NICK FROST: It sounds like you
had something awfully traumatic
happen to you, and this is
something your brain has
invented to cover it.
JACK LOWDEN: [INAUDIBLE].
PAIGE: His wrestling alter ego
reminds me of the alter ego
that I came up with in
case I wasn't Paige.
And it was me and
Renee Young, and we
said we would dress
in dressing gowns.
So I don't know if I'm stealing
your gimmick a little bit.
But we would be
called the sleepers,
and we'll put you
in sleep, and then
we'll give them buns
on their wrists,
and be like, you just
got a case of melatonin.
And then you'd be like, are
you ready for your wet dream.
And then--
LENA HEADEY: Oh, my god.
NICK FROST: Oh, wow.
PAIGE: Well, I'm not going
to tell the rest of it.
FLORENCE PUGH: So
it didn't happen.
PAIGE: No, unfortunately, it
didn't sell, but it's an idea.
But you can join.
JACK LOWDEN: I definitely
think there's a gap in WWE.
PAIGE: Yeah.
JACK LOWDEN: I think there's
a market for something
a little bit more
highbrow like that.
PAIGE: Do you have one?
NICK FROST: I think we've filled
enough to allow the question.
PAIGE: There's one
person lined up.
FLORENCE PUGH: He's on a stage.
JACK LOWDEN: Got a light.
AUDIENCE: First off,
thanks for coming out guys.
We really appreciate it.
I'm someone who grew up
kind of watching, like,
the attitude era
of WWE, so there
was a lot of cool crossover.
It's cool that "The
Rock" is in this.
Were there any other stars
from WWE that were on set
helping out that didn't
make it on camera?
PAIGE: Oh, I don't
know that part.
I just know the ones
that were on camera.
And The Miz, he
gets in everything,
so of course, he was on there.
Freaking Mike.
NICK FROST: Big Show
should appear as well.
Right?
PAIGE: Sheamus Big Show.
And--
FLORENCE PUGH: But we had
that-- that was the one day.
So when we shot at Monday
Night Raw, we were there,
and we were kind of
milling about waiting
for our opportunity to go
on after the show was over.
So Stephen was actually
just going down
the whole thing like, hi,
anybody want to be in the film?
Please be in the film.
And so all these--
JACK LOWDEN: And Vince
Vaughn walked past.
FLORENCE PUGH: Yeah.
Exactly.
These massive
wrestlers were just
walking about in
their little Speedos,
and like, we were just
hoping that they'd
be doing a gag with me and the
food, and then [INAUDIBLE]..
PAIGE: Oh, that was
a good one though.
FLORENCE PUGH: Yeah.
PAIGE: That was like me
when I first got there.
I was just like--
everyone was like, you shouldn't
eat that much, and I'm like,
I'll eat whatever I want to.
And I'm just grabbing hot
dogs, burgers, and everything.
All the girls were eating
like salads, like--
and I'm just like,
no, I like food.
That was perfect.
I loved it.
Oh, that was--
LENA HEADEY: Sorry.
PAIGE: There was that one
question for you guys.
MIKE ABRAMS: Anyway,
I'll keep asking then.
FLORENCE PUGH: Yeah.
MIKE ABRAMS: So how--
NICK FROST: Thank you
everyone for your--
MIKE ABRAMS: Yeah.
NICK FROST: Really.
MIKE ABRAMS: There we go.
NICK FROST: Oh, hang on.
You're not using the bathroom.
JACK LOWDEN: Yeah.
NICK FROST: Oh, he's
off to do a shit.
Well, hello.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I had to think of a
question really quick,
because I didn't want to
miss this opportunity.
But I'm Irish, so
I'm not from the US.
And I noticed there's like
a different sense of humor
in the US than there is
in the UK and Ireland.
I think we kind of
get each other more.
So how do think
American audiences will
take to the movie?
LENA HEADEY: I think
they'll fucking love it.
FLORENCE PUGH: Yeah.
PAIGE: All the
screeners we went to,
everyone's literally dying
laughing, and I love that.
[INAUDIBLE] crying.
FLORENCE PUGH: You know,
we did have to-- so there
are a couple of the lines.
So there's a really
good line in it,
"dick me dead,
bury me pregnant."
And when we'd be
filming, Stephen
would have to basically measure
how many "dick me deads"
each person could get.
So like, if someone
said the F word,
or if someone said dick, or--
it would be like a
tally so there'd only
be a certain amount of
fucks and dicks and willies.
PAIGE: Yeah.
I heard they had to change that.
FLORENCE PUGH: Yeah.
PAIGE: Just for
American audiences.
FLORENCE PUGH: Yeah.
PAIGE: Because it was
"fuck me dead, marry me--"
FLORENCE PUGH: Yeah.
You're only allowed, like, two--
PAIGE: Yeah.
FLORENCE PUGH: "Fuck me
deads, bury me pregnants."
PAIGE: America.
FLORENCE PUGH: And "The Rock"
wasn't even allowed to say it.
All that power.
LENA HEADEY: Did that
answer your question?
NICK FROST: I'm
sorry you asked now.
FLORENCE PUGH: What
was the question?
NICK FROST:
Sensibilities in comedy--
FLORENCE PUGH: Oh.
NICK FROST: Internationally.
FLORENCE PUGH: You
can answer that one.
PAIGE: Was that the
answer to that question?
NICK FROST: Oh-- look, OK.
So I mean, I think if
you try and dilute or try
and second guess what an
international audience will
like, I think you
dilute what the thing is
that made people laugh.
Do you know what I mean?
So I think of things I've
made in the past, comedically,
that have worked
all over the place.
You just do what makes
your mates laugh, really.
And I think I've found
all over the world there
is that gang of people that
them feel like what you've made
is speaking to them
and you directly.
You know?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
NICK FROST: End of answer.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
NICK FROST: Thanks.
MIKE ABRAMS: So I would
love to hear what your--
NICK FROST: Let us go home.
We're a bit bored.
No, I'm joking.
Oh, whoa!
LENA HEADEY: That's Zak.
NICK FROST: This is Zak Zodiac.
PAIGE: This is my brother.
ZAK ZODIAC: I don't
have a question.
In fact, I just wanted
to talk to you, Jack.
That's the first time I've
heard you say anything.
My sister's told me about all
the interviews you've done.
But you know, I
just stood there,
and you just made a six
foot 318 stone guy cry.
JACK LOWDEN: Oh.
ZAK ZODIAC: I
wanted to make sure
that everyone knew here
how much I appreciate
you playing my character.
And there would have been
no one else I'd rather
have play my character.
Thank you so much.
And thank you for those kind
words you've just given me.
JACK LOWDEN: [INAUDIBLE].
PAIGE: That's so sweet.
[INAUDIBLE]
Let them have a moment.
Yeah.
NICK FROST: Nice.
PAIGE: My dad's going to do the
same thing to you, [INAUDIBLE]..
NICK FROST: [INAUDIBLE].
Come on.
JACK LOWDEN: Yeah.
NICK FROST: Well, that's
a nice place to end it.
I'd like to thank--
I'd like to thank you all for--
MIKE ABRAMS: [INAUDIBLE].
I agree.
NICK FROST: Let's
have a look at clip.
MIKE ABRAMS: If there's
no other question,
that's a beautiful
moment to end on.
So--
NICK FROST: One more.
Jesus, we've flown
thousands of miles.
There's two people at Google
who wants to ask a question.
Ah, three, there we go.
AUDIENCE: How are
you guys doing?
Thanks for coming.
NICK FROST: Thank you.
Thank you for asking a question.
AUDIENCE: So growing up
here, wrestling was very much
a part of the popular culture.
When I was a kid, there
was breakfast cereals
and the Saturday
morning cartoons.
And you know, I
was just curious,
in the UK, what is it like?
Is wrestling similar?
Is it part of the
popular culture
in the same way it was here?
Do you-- is our wrestling,
the American wrestling,
popular there?
PAIGE: Yeah, American wrestling
is very popular over there
actually.
That's why we do two
tours a year over there.
It's pretty successful
when we do go.
And yeah, British
wrestling was a huge thing.
We had World of Sport growing
up, and stuff like that.
And [INAUDIBLE] Big Daddy.
NICK FROST: Yeah.
PAIGE: So but it's really grown
in the last couple of years
now.
Like, there's just indie
federations everywhere,
and obviously WWE have opened
up a performance center.
I think CUK over there now.
So yeah, it's just as alive
over there as it is here.
We're just a very small country.
So obviously
there's not as many.
NICK FROST: I used to watch
wrestling on a Saturday
morning.
It was on for like an hour in
the mornings, and that was it.
You know?
And there was, as Paige said,
a character called "Big Daddy"
and another guy called
"Giant Haystacks."
And they were always-- they
started off in their own--
they were a tag team, and
then, essentially, they
became enemies.
So to watch those
two guys going at it,
that was my kind of
beginning of wrestling.
And it was always,
I think, maybe, you
know, the birth of
where WAW started in,
small little halls
around the country.
And it would travel, and the
guy who presented it was a guy
called Dicky Davis.
And he was very Dapper.
And he had dense,
big black hair,
but he had like a
white streak in it,
like the mom at the
end of "Poltergeist."
So that-- yeah,
that's where wrestling
started for me as well.
You know?
AUDIENCE: It feels like a love
child of "Big Daddy" and "Giant
Haystacks."
NICK FROST: Yeah.
In many ways.
I keep trying to think
a biopic of their battle
would be a great
film, but I keep--
it keeps getting knocked back.
People keep saying, well,
it's too British perhaps,
and it wouldn't travel,
but I think that's shit.
Look, we've opened up a gate.
AUDIENCE: Everyone,
thanks for coming.
So to go on that
question, if you
were a fan of
wrestling growing up,
who was your favorite
wrestler and why?
PAIGE: Can I answer
this question?
Because I know I've always
been a fan of wrestling.
Obviously, it's obvious.
But I really loved--
I don't know how big
of wrestling fans
you guys are in
here, but there's
a woman called [INAUDIBLE].
And I was a really
big fan of hers,
because she was very different.
She was this really big
Asian, just beautiful woman,
and she was just so different
to the rest of the women in WWE.
And that's where I stole
one of my wrestling moves,
apart from Zaks, but--
and then, also I love Lea,
because she was very different.
And obviously, Dwayne, I'll put
you up there if he's watching.
And "Stone Cold," because he
just was just a bad ass dude.
He was so amazing.
No one else liked
wrestling, so--
NICK FROST: I think that "Stone
Cold" was one of my favorites.
And of the old English bunch,
I like "Big Daddy" and "Giant
Haystacks," but
when Kendo Nagasaki,
when he ran into
the ring, he was he
was shrouded in
like a Kendo mask.
He was kind of frightening
and and mysterious.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
NICK FROST: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hey guys.
Thanks for coming.
This question is for Paige.
One quick thing I
did want to say,
that what you've done
for women's wrestling
has been amazing.
PAIGE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: And I
really appreciate.
That being said, where do
you see it going from here?
PAIGE: It's just going to
keep getting bigger, I think.
Now we have a WWE Evolution.
I mean, I'm sad that I can't
be a part of that because
of the injury that I had, but--
FLORENCE PUGH: But
you started it.
PAIGE: Though I did
start the damn thing.
So no, I'm just really
happy with where it's going.
We have so many amazing females
now that's in the company,
and they're just main event
in all these big things,
like Wrestlemania.
I never thought that
was going to happen,
but hopefully it's
happening this year.
And I just think it's just
going to keep getting bigger.
Women in the WWE
are now unstoppable.
We're not looked at as
a piss break or like
tits and ass anymore.
We're looked at as truly
serious in the ring competitors,
and no longer divas, but we're
superstars, and I love that.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Hey, thank you.
Thank you guys for coming.
Didn't know if that was working.
This is probably
mostly for Paige,
but it could be for everyone.
You have a moment in the
film, or in the trailer,
where you're talking
about, hey, don't
be the first-- or, don't
be me, be the first you.
Right?
So I'm wondering how people
develop their personas.
You know, how does somebody
become a hero or villain?
And that might make more
sense, obviously, in wrestling.
It could also apply to
actors, who gets cast as what.
How does that work?
PAIGE: Right.
So when it comes to
the WWE, you have
to try and develop a character.
It doesn't matter what it is.
Like, we had Hornswoggle, who
would dress like a leprechaun.
He was a midget.
I don't know if that's
the right term to say.
But it's that WWE can give you
a character, like they gave it
to him.
Or you know-- but with me,
I create my own character,
because I was just like the
elevated version of myself.
You know, I just
started screaming a lot
and being extra pale.
[INAUDIBLE]
And apparently it worked.
But like, with the process,
you have so much time in NXT
that you can
develop a character.
Like, they have such a great
center down there where
you have promo
classes, and you have
teachers that can
work with you to try
and help you create something.
And but I think the best
character you can have
is definitely just you with
the bass turned up essentially.
So that's personally for me.
What do you guys think for
your wrestling characters?
Are you OK?
Wait, what are you laughing at?
NICK FROST: Lena's
laughing at Hornswoggling.
PAIGE: That was his name.
Is there-- do people
know who Hornswoggle was?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PAIGE: One person, I think.
Oh, and the one in the back.
He was Hornswoggle.
There was also another
one called El Torito,
and he dressed
like a little bull.
FLORENCE PUGH: What?
PAIGE: We've had
some characters.
LENA HEADEY: I feel like
we've entered another realm.
PAIGE: Not the kind of
realm you're thinking about.
FLORENCE PUGH: You're crying.
PAIGE: You look--
LENA HEADEY: It's
been three days.
MIKE ABRAMS: On
that note, the film
was going to be in theaters
everywhere on February 22nd,
so please go see it.
And you can find
out more information
at FightingWithMyFamily.movie.
So thank you all for being here.
NICK FROST: Thank you.
Thanks for having us.
Cheers.
PAIGE: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]